reality TV's most famous X's are added
again it really does look like John and
Kate Plus hate she's blasting him in a
brand new expose and the timing is
really interesting because John just
fired away at her when he sat down with
us so here's the big question is Kate
out for revenge I don't really talk to
my ex-wife so it's all kind of just
helter skelter like I have my life and
she has her life
I'm not in care I don't see that much or
often we're kind of not talking right
now and then Collin I haven't seen for a
really long time just six days after
John told us that Kate shot this cover
article for People magazine which hit
Stan's Friday inside there's more than a
few nasty swipes at John Kate blasts her
ex I thought he'd have been here for the
long haul and 15 year-old Maddie
irate that her dad went on TV says he
doesn't even know us he should think
about why we don't want to see him and
the last thing I have time for is a
toxic relationship I'm adding characters
stop coming around 12 13 and then I
didn't question up there moving into
womanhood they'll be 60 in October so I
hope I can talk to them and develop a
relationship in the future so is it up
to Kate who can come or who can't come
that particular day well apparently it's
up to Kate because she doesn't open our
gate those kids can't come down the kids
that I do get are Hannah Leah Joel and
Aaden sometimes I get Alexis um but not
often
I had just signed up for a blind date
find a husband so she doesn't die alone
Kate and the kids are clearly moving on
but the big bombshell Collin has been
sent away from the home the 12 year old
who has quote special needs is in a
program designed to help him develop
better life skills to deal with his
educational and social challenges you
have not seen Colin tears I used to go
to school and see him and then he's
homeschooled well I want you compass
like well you know mommy you know it
doesn't let me down and I
it felt like she was just segregating me
from him the kids obviously are still in
his life because he's their dad and they
visit him from time to time but
otherwise he lives his own life John who
you remember DJ's for a living is upset
about the article Kate who admits she
has all the kids in therapy has a
different way of looking at things
I live with no regrets and everything I
do I know that they're watching